can you tell me a little bit about what
the mindset was and obviously going into
knowing that you're gonna do episode
seven alone is daunting but the fact
that you're setting the tone for the new
trilogy because it's it's the prequels
are very different from say the original
trilogy and you wanted to go more into
the practical effects and you're setting
the blueprint can you tell me a little
bit about that sure it was something
that Cathy Kennedy and and Lawrence
Kasdan and I talked about at the very
beginning which was what we wanted the
feeling to be when people went to see
this movie and there were things about
the original trilogy that for me partly
because they came out when I was 11
years old and it was you know it was a
groundbreaking mind-expanding thing but
the idea for me and for all of us I
think was to try and recapture that
spirit it didn't need to be redefined to
just need needed to be brought back for
me which was that that sense of romance
of comedy of adventure of surprise of a
threat of heartbreak of exhilaration it
was just it was amazing to see what
George Lucas was was able to do in that
in that first movie and we all really
you know we're striving for to recapture
that feeling and telling a brand new
story I know that we have no Ryan
Johnson doing up so late and then
contrib are doing episode 9 I love
college horrible whatever was ever a
chance or even a thought that you would
come back for episode 9 I remember
feeling when I was working on this movie
we were sort of midway through
production and I felt that I didn't
think that it would have been given what
we were all giving to seven something
that I was going to be able to do in in
you know in any way that would do
service to the movie to do eight meaning
I knew I would need some time off
it wouldn't work on their schedule it
wouldn't have been the right thing I
knew if seven worked as well as I was
hoping it would then that's a wonderful
place to have done you know my part in
the Star Wars
and step back and if it didn't go as
well as I was hoping it would no one
would want me to do the next one so
there was only a win to say this was the
movie to direct Star Wars has been
rumored to do TV if TV ever came around
in and say the Netflix area is that's
something you'd want to explore you know
I would certainly be open to anything
but Kathy Kennedy who's overseeing all
of the Star Wars universe is someone who
you know I've known and admired for so
long and I would I've learned certainly
in this experience never say you know no
without really exploring what the what
the possibility is but my focus is is
not going to be on Star Wars after this
movie is over that will be for riot and
Kathy and company to do well GJ thank
you very much on behalf of a friend
angle we wanted to give you this
specialized force awakens gift card all
right and enjoy the movies thank you
baby projectors